hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer a question
from one of my readers Veronica who
wrote in asking about a website for her
brother so she's got a brother in
Winchester UK who's an osteopath the
chiropractor he's had a website that
he's had for six years traffic has
dropped a lot recently he she's going to
build him a new website has bought two
different domains when zecom one's a dot
coat UK because in the UK and she's one
is it worthwhile to move him to one of
the domains from his original website if
so which one and it's better to have the
keywords in the domain name or to use an
established site so let's quickly just
check out this site to see if there's
something that is glaringly wrong on it
start so the design is pretty bad and
could use some serious loving here
there's odds at the bottom which are
probably not needed I'm sure he doesn't
make much from here and he's you know
probably trying to sell his his services
instead I also take off this link to
know that website company unless that's
part of the agreement that was built in
well that edit button does too it's a
little scary let's see what else we have
so treatment will click in locations you
know looking at these pages there's not
a lot of content right like the
treatment page should be full of content
that talks about what he does the
homepage to doesn't have a lot of
content and this could be why he got
penalized has been a number of penalties
that I've come out recently to penalize
websites that do not have good strong
content so I'd look at try to add 500
words of content each page here and see
if it doesn't improve his rankings as
well as try to get a you know a couple
links coming into the site in terms of
your question here I would rather focus
on a website that's older like this one
and improve the rankings because all the
domains have a easier time to rank and
if they have any kind of external link
profile you can check in your webmaster
tools to see how well it's been ranking
in the past
and what kind of links that he have if
he's got any kind of link profile I
would I would stick with the older
website you could still use these
websites these two new ones just to rank
for that keyword so Winchester what is
it osteopath then from you know you
could rank for that keyword you can
throw up a little site just targeting
that keyword and try to rank for that
keyword if that's important one for him
and focus all of your long tail and all
your content other keywords on the main
site here that's why what i would do see
if i could get this page from out of a
penalty yeah also look at the webmaster
tools to see if there's anything else
that's showing up if Google's not
crawling him as much if there's any
errors on his page or if he has a site
map where pages aren't being indexed I
look at all that but definitely add more
content improve the look of the page add
more content and go after the long tail
for the for this main page so I hope
that helps if you guys liked the video
please give it a thumbs up below and
lots a little love to hear what you have
to think if you want to leave a comment
under the video and stay tuned for next
episode
you